are you looking forward to God of War on  ps4 well  the devs just hit a big milestone I'm  Tony and this GameSpot news update is in  development God of War was not present  at PlayStation experience but director  Corey bar logs says that's no reason to  be concerned  in fact he recently tweeted that the  game is now playable from start to  finish of course that doesn't mean the  game is going gold anytime soon but bar  log did say the team will show off more  awesome footage whenever it's ready  hopefully we'll see something soon God  of War was first revealed at this  summer's e3 no release date has been  given but it's expected to be a ps4  exclusive stay tuned to game spot for  more quotes from Corey bar log and for  all the latest on God of War you're  already in the right place  [Music]